which means I over invested more people
more capabilities because I'm gonna take
the whole [ __ ] pie
[Music]
I think you this was last Monday morning
a delight
[Music]
here cuz you're still you're still
recording right so weird how the world's
going now right like we're like okay so
worst advice what is the worst advice
you've received along the way
almost everything anybody's ever told me
I mean my advice is bad
unless it's contextual and you really
dig deep I give very little advice to my
employees until I start to really get to
know them the advice you know that I
give them comes with really getting to
know them Emily's advice got better
every day because I got to know her
better and so most people like to give
advice without context the best advice
only comes from the people closest to
you and the ones that I can actually
have your best interest in mind not
theirs
that means almost nobody because that
means everybody setting outside and a
lot of times the people on the inside I
mean mommy and daddy are giving you
advice in their best interest not yours
I just don't listen to anybody I'm sure
but I'll take where I'm at great thank
you guys you can't put it out but you
know anyway this was super fun let me
know if I could be helped bye guys good
luck
okay you know it's one of those classic
when they do something it pops up a
different way right yeah but unlike
unlike me you're an attractive woman and
that gives you eight billion ship things
that I don't
no you have to understand like so does
Facebook allows us to everything does
triggers the Twitter's the watercooler
of our society I I know you get it cuz
you're [ __ ] smart I know it sucks but
it's just gonna you put you put you put
up you put a finger in that hole and
that water is gonna come somewhere else
we need to attack mental health and
other issues and many other issues
racism equality more meritocracy and
capitalism but in a different way
there's a million things we have to do
but I promise you shutting down Twitter
or forcing real names and Twitter is is
the furthest thing you're trying to fix
the faucet the problem is in the well my
dear like I'm a like guy like I'm I
don't want them after like the first
taping everybody's like the three of
them being like we're about to launch
something called Bainer Talent it is
basically this it's what I believe is
the next version of the tune of the
production companies it's the human
production company it is the combination
of influencing our social media
marketing and reality TV it's the unique
thing that I've done nobody's done for
last six months it's the reason that
even though I've been the best of his
craft for nine years that over the last
six months everything has changed for me
I've got to figure it out
I've built a team around it I've taken
my members and built the division around
it and we're gonna do it and I so I can
take any b-list celebrity you have and
make them a list and I'm be dead [ __ ]
serious with you right now for $25,000 a
month dead serious okay all right I'll
see you in a few minutes
[Music]
top dog it's a better way to put it
around I have a vision for education
which is unbelievable huh no it's just I
just have my I have my version I believe
in everything just not the way you guys
want to do it here's what it could be
7:00 to 11:00 p.m. night classes all
hands on one shot go sit like I'm gonna
have my version but it's gonna work it's
gonna work being the point person from
team that's gonna create the ACCA II
what it means to be an account Orson
we're gonna literally change the company
in five minutes
let's um let's put this up there to next
to that we could have to move that one
over cuz it got centered but this one
too
all right ASAP Alex is what he's doing
Alison can you hang this next to that
thing fix it I trust Alex more he's not
doing anything
and he looks handy as [ __ ] cool yeah I
need way more of my face around this
office I think let me give you some
really good advice when you win on a
macro level don't over stress the micro
level there's unlimited opportunity it's
just priorities it's a macro thing you
know as long as I'm not stressing about
the micro you shouldn't stress about the
mic round
I'm not so sold you aren't better off to
go take the jump fail and come back then
to wait a year to take the job I don't
know you're doing all the right things
coz being respectful as [ __ ] and really
trying to be careful here because you
know on the on the insurance policy so
I'm just not so sold that you shouldn't
jump try to yeah because you'll come
back right now you don't know and it's
[ __ ] eating you you're better off to
go fail first a win easy right
[ __ ] yes fail get that nut off come
back for three years and then try it
again or come back and never try it
again
but boy will you know a lot more
I'd love to be able to say to our
clients that we can do their social
media well you don't want you don't want
to send them to us so that you aren't
interested before
okay I don't have a phone anymore I got
a new book about right now but I want to
know what it is so that you've done
[Music]
you know the best part is how awesome it
is that the whole thing is recorded and
if they want to take it in the wrong
direction I'm thrilled to put out all
the content
hello so you know I'm really thinking
that Q&A is the way to go here I'm never
on defense
I'll bail I'll bail every when I when I
was dating if I saw anything that wasn't
good if I did it so I hate negativity
it's why we have a great culture if I
date a girl that I realized very quickly
like she liked the in like it was
intriguing to have conflict I literally
bailed a meeting out forever
I just I have no effort for defense I'm
trying to win every game for 77 to 433
and I'm talking about baseball you know
what I mean like it's beautiful
but you know what I mean but but
baseball where there's lower scoring
that's why that's the announced your
[ __ ] soccer like I'm trying to I'm
trying to I'm trying to score so many
points that I'm not worried about the
casualties I mean you know this more
because you've been at Vayner so it's
like like I never care about the
failures at Boehner I love when people's
come in to me be like listen I got to
talk to you about this problem it's
really gonna undermine us I'm like are
you a [ __ ] idiot how the [ __ ] do you
think we got here if you want me to play
your micro game I'm gonna look like
everybody else so I'm always on the
offense always macro and always very
aware of what I want to happen we're
gonna make less money this year at a
hundred million that we made last year
at 67 net I don't mean percentage net
because I'm getting greedier meaning
they're in trouble I see it which means
I over invested more people more
capabilities because I'm gonna take the
whole [ __ ] pie I care about
capitalism and meritocracy and the game
more than I care about myself and that
is crazy [ __ ] and I don't I really don't
see it and I only because I haven't
gotten close to it or been figured out
how to see it in others but it is a
different thing when you get to that
level of selflessness
it's a vulnerability that is so extreme
and it just it's so in mean I just think
I'm cut out for it and I don't want to
force my audience into it because their
behavior probably hasn't been their
whole life to be in it got it Tyler did
the email did he email just a company go
out 99% of the market is shorter and the
1% that isn't and has the talent wins
every time
which makes no sense because unless
you're gonna die he should only play a
long term there was a stat that some
dude in Mexico City said one of these
like futuristic type of characters I'm
sure he's smart I have no idea who so I
just but he was right before me as I was
miked up and he says it's been
scientifically proven stat 85% of what
humans make decisions about is
irrational and that's spoke to me
because a I think it's higher and B it's
why I think all my success is happening
I am stunningly the most rational and
the most practical of all yet I don't
seem it and it when he said in like
right that's why because the rest of the
market is irrational
d-roc there's more time generals and
there's peacetime generals
[Music]
[Music]